fútbol hay noticia de la copa américa
femenina que se pueden colombia y por
supuesto tenemos cubrimiento especial si
andrés cuarta fecha del grupo b dos
partidos transcurre en este lunes en la
ciudad de armenia ya conocemos el
resultado del encuentro que abrió la
jornada hablamos del duelo entre brasil
y venezuela- por eso nos vamos a cali
otra de las sedes de esta copa américa
femenina con nuestra enviada especial
estefanía montero estefanía detalles de
ese partido
pues la noticia que tenemos el día de
hoy es que ya tenemos a la primera
clasificada a las semifinales de esta
copa américa y no podía ser más más que
otra selección que la favorita
multicampeona
protagonista a nivel mundial de este
fútbol suramericano hablamos de brasil
venció cuatro goles por cero a la
selección de venezuela en un primer
tiempo en el que parecía que la ventaja
no era mucho en el que venezuela se
plantó muy bien en la cancha incluso lo
intentó en varias oportunidades y
terminó un gol por cero pero ya en el
segundo tiempo todo se desencadenó todo
fluyó más para las brasileras y lograron
marcar tres tantos más la figura de la
cancha de viña que se convierte además
en una de las goleadoras de este
certamen a segunda hora y en pocos
minutos uruguay enfrentará a la
selección de perú en un duelo que podrán
definir quien ocupe el cuarto la cuarta
posición de este grupo muy reñida esta
copa américa pero brasil ya tiene su
tiquete a las semifinales